und jetzt jetzt noch mal richtig bunt
[Musik]
die hauptstadt feiert unterm regenbogen
und alles ist schrill laut und bunt mehr
als 500.000 menschen tanzten am samstag
beim csd mit sie zogen in einer bunten
parade durch die berliner innenstadt und
demonstrierten gegen gewalt sowie gegen
benachteiligung von lesben schwulen und
transgender und wir waren mittendrin und
ich bin froh dass wir in deutschland so
leben können wie wir leben und das
zeigen wir mit dem csd mir heute nur
fast die ganzen familie hierher gekommen
und ich bin das drama platziert werden
außerhalb von verdi namen yahoo von
rudow foto normalerweise ja nur die
futura taube die ich da besucher du hast
die tiefe stürzen habe heute auf ihr
dann wenn du das sagen lassen zeigen die
lange gebraucht und die so hoch drei
monate nach seinem nein aber es hält
es ist wichtiges signal finde ich dass
der chef dahinter steht das voll
unterstützt hat sich seit vielen jahren
aber wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin habe ich
wollte ihn selber spaß
man sollte bei so einer sache auch nicht
vergessen all jene die eben seit
1974 dafür gekämpft haben das heute
möglich
dass diese demonstration von der politik
gehört wird zeigt eine geste ganz
besonders zum ersten mal in der
geschichte wurde die regenbogenflagge
auf dem bundestag ist
[Musik]
jetzt ist er heute noch hier in so einer
stadt wie berlin gerade auf die
lesbische paare ganz
[Musik]
alles gleich ist
werdet ihr auch noch diskriminiert hier
in der stadt wie berlin
das kommt das so vor
ich weiß immer noch aufklärung bedeutet
immer noch
[Musik]
geburtstag sexualität dass wir immer
noch dagegen ankämpfen
sanierung ist einfach super wichtig dass
wir immer noch auf die straße gehen
da sind dass sie sich
nach zwei jahren corona pause ist er
wieder zurück der christopher street day
eine riesen party mit starken
politischen motiven und dem aufruf zu
mehr toleranz gegenüber allen formen der
liebe in deutschland und der gesamten
welt es gibt immer noch in ganz vielen
bereichen menschen die damit ein problem
haben oder die intoleranz gegen schule
am tag leben und solange noch welche ich
verstanden habe dass jeder das einer
fast aus dem web soll nun bald noch ein
bisschen arbeit vor uns
[Musik]
[Applaus]